I always rush those videos at
the end because right when I
was talking I saw that I was
getting kind of down on the
YouTube 10 minute limit, but I
just want to make sure that
you understand what I did.
I used the first few examples--
and essentially
what they told us-- to figure
out an equation that tells me
well, if I know the term
t, how do I get
the t'th term, right?
Actually, it works here too.
We could write 8 plus
9 t minus 1.
Because here, this is the first
term, so this t minus 1
term goes to 0, and that's
why we only have 8.
And it works on all of these,
and it makes sense.
Every term is going to be 9 more
than the previous one.
We start at 8, and the reason
why it's t minus 1 instead of
t is because we only start
adding 9 after the first term.
For example, if this was
actually 9, 18, 27, if we just
went like that, we could've
just said
it's 9 times t, right?
That could have been
the formula.
Or we could've said 9 plus
9 times t minus 1.
These would have been
the same thing.
But it started at 8, so that's
why we had to make it a little
bit more cloogy.
Hopefully that explains it
a little bit better.
Let's do the next problem.
Problem six I will
do in yellow.
They draw a bunch of lines,
so they draw three lines.
One line, two lines, then
we have a third line.
OK, so this is s degrees, r
degrees, t degrees, z degrees,
y and x degrees.
Three lines intersect
in a point as shown
in the figure above.
Which of the following pairs
of angle measures is not
sufficient for determining
all six angle measures?
Is not, so they're going
to make us go
through all of them.
Hopefully one of the
early choices.
So choice a, t and z.
So I'm going to do choice
a in this brown color.
So choice a, t and z.
Well first of all, if I know
t, I immediately know z
because they're opposite
angles, right?
So I could figure out that.
I could figure out that.
Well if I know either of those,
I could then figure
out-- let's see, in order to do
anything from here, I need
to know one of the
other angles.
And this is actually the way you
should think about it. t
and z only gives us the
relationship between these two
purple lines, right?
It essentially tells us at what
angle these two purple
lines intersect.
But it gives us no information
about the angle that this
yellow line intersects, right?
Think about it, if I welded
these purple lines together, I
could still move this yellow
line around without
changing t or z.
So there's no way just knowing
t or z I can figure out what
angle this yellow line is at.
And if you did the other
choices, you could try it out.
For example, if I didn't know t
and instead they told me r,
then I would be in business.
If I knew r, for example, then
I could use the fact that s,
r, and z all form one line.
And I could figure out s.
If I knew z, then I
could figure out t
because they're opposite.
If I know r, I could
figure out s
because they're opposite.
And then if I knew s, I could
figure out y, right?
So z and t alone will not help
you, so our choice is a.
And normally on the SAT when
they give you something where
you have to kind of try out
every choice they give you,
it's normally going to be one
of the first choices because
they try to make the questions
as fast as possible.
They don't want you to
waste too much time.
If you ever see yourself wasting
too much time on a
question, you're not necessarily
doing it wrong,
but you may not be doing it
the quickest possible way.
Problem number seven.
The sum of two numbers that
differ by one is t.
So let's call those two
numbers x and y.
We know that the sum of x
plus y is equal to t.
But we also know that the
numbers differ by 1.
And then they say in terms of
t, what is the value of the
greater of the two numbers.
So let's just assume that
x is greater than y.
Let's just write x is
greater than y.
So that means that x minus y is
going to be equal to what?
Well they told us that the
sum of two numbers
that differ by 1.
So x is actually exactly
1 more than y.
So that when I subtract
y from x I get 1.
So if I want to know the value
of the greater of the two
numbers-- I defined x, actually,
as the greater of
the two numbers-- I just have
to solve the system of
equations for x.
So let's add the
two equations.
x plus x is 2x.
What's y plus negative y?
Well, they cancel out, right?
0.
Then what's t plus 1?
Well it's t plus 1.
And now to solve for x, you
get x is equal to-- divide
both sides by 2 or multiply
by 1/2-- t plus 1 over 2.
And we are done.
And that is choice c.
Next problem.
Problem number eight.
This color is getting
obnoxious.
OK, number of siblings per
student in a preschool class.
So let me draw this chart.
So this is number of siblings,
number of students.
The table above shows how many
students in a class of 12
preschoolers had 0, 1,
2, or 3 siblings.
OK, right, I haven't actually
included the information.
0, 1, 2, 3.
So 3 kids had 0 siblings, 6 kids
had 1 sibling, 2 kids had
2 siblings, and then 1
kid had 3 siblings.
Later, a new student joined
the class, and the average
number of siblings per student
became equal to the median
number of siblings
per student.
How many siblings did the
new student have?
Fascinating.
OK, so let's say the new
student has x siblings.
x siblings is how many
the new student has.
So we don't know where the new
student falls in, but let's
figure out where the average and
the median are before the
student even joins.
So the median number
of siblings.
The average number of siblings
per student became equal to
the median number of siblings
per student.
So what is the average number
of siblings per student?
We just add the number of
siblings for all of the
students, so we should get 12
terms. So we can multiply 3
times 0-- that's essentially 0
plus 0 plus 0-- plus 6 times
1, plus 2 times 2, plus 3
times 1, divided by 12.
This is the current average
of siblings per student.
This is 0, so this equals
6 plus 4 plus 3 over
12, which is what?
13.
This equals 13/12,
which is 1 1/12.
So before this new student
joins, there's 1 1/12.
This is the average.
That's before the new
student joins.
What's the median?
Let's list out all of the-- let
me do it in another color
because I'm running out of
space-- so I have a 0, 0, 0,
there are three students
with 0.
Then you have 6 students
with 1.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Then you have how many
students with 2?
2, 2.
And then one student with 3.
So there are 12 terms in all,
and what's the middle one?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So the middle term is 6.
So the median before that
student joined is 1, right?
And the average before that
student joined is a little bit
over one, it's 1 1/12.
So the only way that you can
bring the average down--
right, because that's
essentially what we have to
do, this new student-- to bring
this average down, he
either has to have 1 sibling
or 0 siblings.
Or 0 siblings.